you create a racism of soft expectations
and there is no way first off this
questionnaire could possibly create any
consistency it is guaranteed to create
more racism students at San Diego State
University are now offered extra credit
if they take a quiz to determine their
level of white privilege so this story
comes to us professor de Elliot offered
the option to her sociology class
students a white privilege checklist
that includes 20 questions that aim to
illustrate quote racial privilege is one
form of privilege so what is white
privilege well listen we're gonna take
the quiz today right here and the quiz
lets us know from peggy mcintosh
associate director of Wellesley College
Center for Research on women so you know
it's good describe white privilege as an
invisible package of unearned assets
which I can count on cashing in each day
what about which I was meant to remain
oblivious white privilege is an
invisible weightless knapsack of special
provisions massive about okay so we
decided that we were going to take the
test here today these are actual
questions this is being given out in
college so question of the day do you
think that you're the beneficiary of
white privilege and who benefits from
more privileged the upper-middle class
black American or brown American or
immigrant whose parents are wealthy have
college degrees and got to go to good
schools lived in a good area or the
white fatherless child from a trailer
park in Arkansas different strokes we
should address the elf in the room first
Comic Sans about why privileged
following our examples
according to this list of ways white
individuals have privilege because they
are white so please read the list and
place a check next to the privileges
that apply to you or those that you can
you can play along at home like family
future one exactly but the one where you
always lose just follow the bouncing
number one I can arrange to be in the
company of people of my race most of the
time okay
let's I know you I have literally never
made those arrangements yeah never come
up like hey hey hey you know we should
really get the wives together tonight do
you want to have
oh wait Hong she's not coloured is she I
know you haven't done this cracker
because you miss our white party every
Tuesday night never there number two I
can go shopping alone most of the time
pretty well assured that I will not be
followed or harassed well not if you're
an attractive woman don't know the ones
you got the most harassed in a I guess
the implication here is that they're
following you around I assume probably
if you're an ethnic minority though
again I mean listen it depends where you
are in which neighborhood you are
because that would determine the profile
of somebody who stole their last pair of
kicks at Foot Locker I don't blame the
guy making 750 an hour it depends where
you are it depends what the demographics
are context matters context matters
alright number three I can turn on the
television or open the front page of the
paper and see people of my race widely
represented this is a good example of
how of how leftists are just constantly
dealing in the past bringing reopening
old wounds slavery you go back to the
Civil War newspapers today that would be
relevant I can turn the television or
hunt paper to see well I go Kay
depending it on to be et this is true
where am i turning it on to oxygen I
mean this will determine what I see I
mean this is something that's that's
it's less relevant than ever because
media is so it's so fractioned yeah
people can pick whatever they want
people set their homepages it's also why
we live more of a political echo chamber
than ever by the way they also wrote
about number four when I'm told about
our national heritage or about
civilization I am shown that people of
my color made it what it is
wait what no one's taught that people of
your color we're taught that good people
made civilization what it is okay this
is it they may have people taking this
test what does this said it says two
people who are not white they think we
have like secret textbooks that they
don't have yeah so the
founding of America which was entirely
white all the history books about Rosa
Parks and Harriet Tubman along with the
monuments white people put them up
you're welcome
this is the divide-and-conquer that
people don't first up this this it
creates this idea of a monolith yeah
which marginalizes any minority more
than they intend to and it's also really
stupid number five I can be sure that my
children will be given curricular
materials that testify to the existence
of their race okay to the question of
the day okay request it can anyone out
there who has children Senate says it's
Senate to be on Twitter or comment below
a desk router or at NACA Jared if any of
you have had children come home with
testify to the existence of their race I
will personally send you a lock of not
gojira's hair but criminais ting number
six I can go into a music shop and count
on finding the music of my race
represented into a supermarket and find
the food I grew up with into a
hairdresser shop and find someone who
can deal with my hair okay oh your lord
this one is just can I go into a music
shop and find my race represented if
you're trying to sit sell this one as
marginalized list just look at the
Billboard Top 100 okay black people are
significantly black people Latinos are
far over-represented in music as goodies
it's a meritocracy apparently so listen
I don't care but you actively you can't
go into a music shop as far as can I go
into a supermarket and find the food I
grew up with well if you if you're at a
supermarket dozen have the food you grew
up with where did you grow up that's the
issue there did you by the way liberals
have entire foundations saying that bad
neighborhoods I remember when I lived in
New York there was this drive for
Spanish Harlem look they don't have
access to healthy food and the obesity
epidemic the diabetes rates in the
American black community is really bad
so maybe it's a good thing that Trader
Joe's came on into your town Whole Foods
in our neck of the woods yeah that's all
we can finally see yours now alle back
to you this is all one question by the
way sorry I hope you're an ear for the
long haul today into a hairdresser shop
and find someone who can deal with my
hair it's funny that you bring that up
because um I was trying to think of an
example of anywhere that you know you
might you might
might find places that could cater
hair-wise to ethnic minorities but then
I found barbershop 1 2 & 3 the beloved
films along with Beauty shot on their
sequel it is actually something that is
so culturally ubiquitous in the black
community that they have films about
them number 7 good stuff whether I use
checks credit cards or cash I can count
on my skin color not to work against the
appearance of financial responsibility
okay if you're using cash credit cards
or checks okay if it's not counterfeit
money if the credit card works and if
the check clears
you're good for everybody's walk in with
as a white person by the way this is not
just this is not just this is just white
privilege so it's basically white versus
everybody so everybody said you know
Asian Indians blacks name and I
obviously Indians are Asian and this
one's gonna leave it coming Asians
Latinos Mexicans black insert whatever
here Middle Eastern so this is white
people versus everybody else what do you
think you think white people walk in
well my credit your credit card doesn't
work oh really that's fine it's on me
you think a black person swipes wrong
now you're here swipe their Amex
Platinum and the house I actually hit
decline please i want to go bankrupt
because you're number eight I am NOT
made acutely aware that my shape bearing
or body odor will be taken as a
reflection I didn't even understand what
this made like I don't think about it
but I guess I guess there are certain
people come from certain parts of the
world this isn't a color thing okay
that's one for you number nine I can
worry about racism without being seen as
self-interested or self-seeking the only
people who could check this box are
everyone who are not white people the
only people who actually cannot wear it
can worry about racism without basing
itself interests ourselves think we're
the only ones who aren't allowed to
we're the only ones who can do that
that's why we're like hey can we have a
conversation about race and they just
tell the professor's no no okay thank
you and they leave let's move on to
number ten I can take a job or enroll in
a college with an affirmative action
policy without having my co-workers or
peers assume I
it because of my race okay here's here's
this is where we start to get into the
meat of this here okay leftists are the
ones who've done a great disservice to
any kind of minority particular black
Americans okay let's let's talk about
this we've done this with affirmative
action they put students into programs
for which they're not qualified and then
they end up in the body 50% bottom 50%
they can't keep up they end up having
more anxiety disorders affirmative
action hurts people it doesn't help
people and yeah it does create people
that just create an environment where
people just they wonder if you've earned
that spot you know you know who's
probably mostly is Asians yeah that's
right but I do better my essay - yeah
sorry pang but we have we have to give
that spot to a black guy you your your
folks do - well I came to I thought it
was meritocracy no used to be number
number 11 I can be late to a meeting
without having the lateness reflect on
my race the fact that this is in here
first off I can be late to a meeting no
one can be late to a meeting second that
your ass and this means that you plan on
perhaps being late to a meeting and the
fact that you're saying hey if I'm late
to this meeting does it does it reflect
on my race means that you're assuming
that it's kind of a negative stereotype
that people of your race are late to
meetings so here's the solution don't
prepare don't be late so time this
question might might as well read thing
that I can be personally completely
unaccountable and childish and it won't
reflect negatively if there is a pattern
of people from my ilk being
irresponsible and challenged by the way
I'm not saying this I didn't really know
I actually I will say I do know but
doing Brazilian Jujitsu they've often
said people run in Brazilian times about
Americans definitely in general but no
call they I know buddy look they call it
CPT time yeah couple time blockable time
oh really any people yeah they call that
themselves they know right then could
you imagine even asking these questions
to a black person even in an affirmative
manner yeah hey I know you're late today
that she won't you know yes and no it's
not because you're black I think this
question I know you're late but just
thinking it listen everyone here we're
like we'd prefer you be on time but
we're not attributing that to you be
okay this test by the way isn't really
circulated to check white privilege this
is something that's designed to stoke
the fires so people who this the fact
that this test exists tells me that
professors like this who create these
tests they're telling their black
students that were somehow being taught
that only white people created
civilization that were somehow being
taught that all black people are late in
that if we're late but it's okay this is
what this is these are this is the
racism of soft expectations this is a
really big problem okay we don't let's
not belittle this because these people
are teaching your children we're going
to be building your planes think of that
for a second number 12
I can choose public accommodation
without fearing that people of my race
cannot get in or will be mistreated well
it's fine that you bring this up because
white people don't have segregated safe
spaces no like you have at Brown and Cal
State and what is University of
Minnesota yeah yeah so as a matter of
fact you can probably name multiple
places where only by people and that's
listen I think that's fine if you want
to have it but let's not act as though
you don't the only place where this
doesn't happen on in public areas again
are for white people this question is
based on a lie
number 14 you can take this again take
this test along with 1303 I've never
asked to speak for all of the people of
my racial group hmm hmm well here's the
thing too
this is what the left doesn't they
always you act as though women feminism
exists in a monolith LGBTQA IP they
exist in a monolith if they're just they
all have the 17 opinion black people all
have the same opinion it's all right
let's let's bring out Farrakhan oh okay
turns out he's a piece of war mongering
violent Sharpton yeah it turns out he's
[ __ ] okay let's bring out the next
black guy right you speak for all black
people it's a Jackson interview well
Jesse Jackson I don't know Van Jones oh
boy right right no I just I don't know
this is you ask people to do it and then
you tell people who don't agree with
your opinion that they aren't black that
they aren't Latino that they're Uncle
Tom there are times that they're not
true that there are women who are
there's a lot loving women because they
don't want to kill their unborn children
number fourteen I can be pretty sure
that if I asked to talk with the person
and
I will be facing a person of my race oh
I can go to this there's a place in town
where I can go and ask to speak to the
person in charge and he will guaranteed
not be a person of my race as a matter
fact I wouldn't even able to ask the
person in charge because I can't ask for
him in Spanish this depends on where you
live is this an inner city Detroit is it
in the beat but is it in Louisiana on
the bayou
this isn't Jacksonville Florida or is it
Miami if you ask to speak to a person
and try to you want in the Baltimore
Council yes speak to anyone in the
Baltimore City Council I'm probably not
going to look like them number 15 stupid
if a traffic cop pulls me over or if the
IRS audits my tax return I can be sure I
haven't been singled out because of my
race listen this is one of those no one
can be sure of any of these things
because it's very difficult to prove as
far as the IRS and when proof that we do
have isn't the Obama administration
actually used it as a political weapon
to target conservatives so pretty sure
that if you pulled that lever for the r
and you're being audited
maybe there's there's reasonable doubt
there all right number 16 I can easily
buy posters postcards picture books
greeting cards dolls toys and children's
magazines featuring people of my race
first off by spelled BY I hope you don't
speak for your entire race cuz going by
the last name I'm guessing if I asked
for the first and I'm in charge right
it's probably not that we probably have
a different makeup shade but it's close
it's very close and then greeting cards
dolls toys children's magazines
featuring people in my race yes yes I'm
pretty sure that anyone in this country
can find picture books greeting cards or
dolls of people of their race as men
reckon no you can't at number 17 I can
choose blemish cover or bandages in
flesh color and have them more or less
match my skin okay
we're scraping the bottom of the barrel
and we're done like a team flesh-colored
a couple of things for some it depends
on where you are it depends on where you
are if you're in a place that is a
majority white meaning that 70 something
or 80 something percent of the
population are going to have a specific
color skin tone they might call it flesh
color but I light here if you're if
you're
he could probably summon but I don't
really I don't know that in a lot of
these countries they have bandages
because that's something that's brought
to you by the modern world again brought
to you by good people not necessarily
any specific person of an individual
race we created bandages whereas in
these other countries perhaps like
Zambia and Mozambique they're still
wrapping wounds with used filthy rags
like us from the Revolutionary War so
we're giving you our bit you're welcome
for bandages unfortunately when we
created bandages we didn't have the
foresight to realize at this point I
think we were probably still trying to
end slavery in some capacity or the
Civil Rights Act we didn't think hey
maybe 85 years or 200 years I don't know
in bandages were invented
someone's gonna [ __ ] about this being a
violation of their civil rights because
I wrote down the name flesh and at that
point we'll call it black but it'll be
too late so damn it I didn't I can't
believe that that eluded me you're
welcome for bandages and we couldn't
retro actively go back and not call it
flesh-colored so we'll give you that one
we're sorry but it's not quite the same
as having a ride at the back of the bus
18 I can do well in a challenging
situation without being called a credit
to my race but this whole but number
four I'm shown the people my color made
it what it is you want to be notified
that it's a credit to your race hey Rosa
Parks did some good stuff she's a crack
turret down rate the same person to
write all these questions
number 18 rose entirely a violation of
number four this is why the left can't
keep it straight out in public the
oppression Olympics the very same person
who's felt by bu iby wrote this and
Connor didn't wait it's only a 20
sound like it's a final I am there
requires number two pencil with a
scantron this is easy steps not even
disturbs just a check mark it's not even
multiple-choice number 19 I can walk
into a classroom and no I will not be
the only member of my race it depends on
which classroom you're walking into is
that the film where Hilary Swank goes to
the wrong
or is it the karate kids school where
everyone looks at Hitler use it depends
where you go to school take the last
question all right
I can enroll in a class at college and
be sure that the majority of my
professors will be of my race couple of
things here I'm so glad this is the last
question first off this is impossible
okay if this is meant to it's talking
about margin about it cannot be that
says majority not plurality okay so you
can't have a majority black you can't
have a majority Latino one of them so
you're gonna have to issue at another
questionnaire talking about your black
leverage or brown privilege we're not
them another segregated only you know
only insert race here space this this
this cannot work someone's getting
cannibalized someone's getting an apple
in their mouth and roasted over a fire
because you demanded a majority not even
a plurality you didn't word this
properly secondly ensure ensure that the
majority of my and be sure said that the
majority my profession will be of my
race okay well let's go back here there
you go number ten I can take a job
enrolling college of the formative
action without my co-workers or peers
assuming that I got it because of my
race well why would they think that
maybe because number twenty asks that
you can be sure that the majority not
plurality of your professors are people
of your race so howdy
how are you sure how can you be certain
that an amount of black people are brown
people are professors you cannot be
certain of anything regarding
demographics in in a meritocracy it'll
be different every single graduating
year so now in number twenty you're
saying I can be sure that a majority of
my teachers will be black and by the way
when a majority of them are black you
cannot assume that it's because we
created the policies but you could be
sure they were a majority black you
create a racism of soft expectations and
there is no way first off this
questionnaire could possibly create any
consistency it is guaranteed to create
more racism and you have no idea no
self-awareness as to the fact that all
of your secondary questions all of your
questions are the second half of this
test completely contradict your first
questions and this is why people don't
respect you also it's spelled by B you
why
Hey did you like this video of course
you did let's there's something wrong
with you in which case you can comment
below what's your problem with this
video we want to hear from you and we
promise you 100% I give you my word as
my bond will answer every single
negative comment for those who are
normal you can leave a thumbs up and
subscribe